Il y a un ancien concept universel où les mots ont un pouvoir,
où les formules magiques existent, et si l'on pouvait seulement prononcer les mots justes,
alors, rrrooouuu ! Une avalanche
emporterait les hobbits, non ? C'est une idée attrayante
parce que nous sommes paresseux, comme l'apprenti sorcier,
ou le meilleur programmeur au monde.
Et donc, cette idée a beaucoup d'empreinte sur nous.
Nous aimons l'idée que lorsque les mots sont prononcés --
ils sont à peine plus que de l'information pure,
mais ils évoquent une action physique
dans le monde réel et nous aident à faire quelque chose.
Avec la quantité d'ordinateurs programmables
et de robots autour de nous c'est une chose facile à imaginer.
Combien d'entre vous savent de quoi je parle ?
Levez la main droite. OK. Combien d'entre vous
ne savent pas de quoi je parle ? Levez la main gauche. OK.
Bon. C'est formidable. C'était beaucoup trop facile.
Vous avez des ordinateurs très incertains, OK ?
Le fait est que c'est une forme différente de formule magique.
C'est un programme d'ordinateur fait de zéros et de uns.
Il peut être prononcé par un ordinateur. Il fait quelque chose comme ça.
L'important c'est que nous pouvons l'écrire dans un langage de haut niveau.
Un magicien de l'informatique peut écrire ceci.
Il peut être compilé en zéros et en uns
et prononcé par un ordinateur.
C'est ce qui rend les ordinateurs puissants:
ces langages de haut niveau qui peuvent être compilés.
Je suis donc ici pour vous dire que vous n'avez pas besoin d'un ordinateur
pour avoir une formule magique. En fait, ce que vous pouvez faire
au niveau moléculaire c'est que si vous encodez de l'information --
vous codez une formule magique ou un programme avec des molécules --
la physique peut ensuite directement interpréter cette information
et exécuter un programme. C'est ce qui se passe dans les protéines.
Quand cette séquence d'acides aminés est prononcée avec des atomes,
ces petites lettres sont collantes l'une pour l'autre.
Elle s'effondre pour former une forme en 3D, ce qui la transforme
en une nanomachine capable de couper de l'ADN.
La chose intéressante est que si vous changez la séquence,
vous changez aussi le pliage en trois dimensions.
Ce qui donne une agrafeuse à ADN à la place. Ce sont le genre de
de programmes moléculaires que nous voulons être capable d'écrire,
mais le problème est que nous ne connaissons pas le langage machine des
protéines; nous n'avons pas de compilateur pour les protéines.
J'ai donc rejoint un groupe de personnes qui essayent de créer
des formules magiques moléculaires en utilisant de l'ADN. Nous utilisons de l'ADN parce que c'est moins cher.
C'est plus facile à manipuler. C'est quelque chose que nous comprenons vraiment bien.
En fait nous le comprenons si bien que nous pensons pouvoir écrire
des langages de programmation pour l'ADN et avoir des compilateurs moléculaires.
Nous pensons pouvoir le faire. Une de mes premières questions en faisant ça
a été : Comment peut-on créer
une forme ou un motif arbitraire avec de l'ADN ? J'ai décidé d'utiliser
un type d'origami d'ADN, où l'on prend un long brin d'ADN
et on le plie dans la forme ou le motif que l'on veut.
Voici une forme. J'ai passé environ un an à la maison,
en sous-vêtements, à coder, comme Linus [Torvalds], dans la photo précédente.
Ce programme prend une forme et recrache 250 séquences d'ADN.
Ce sont ces courtes séquences d'ADN qui vont plier le long brin
et lui donner la forme que l'on veut créer. Vous envoyez un courriel
avec ces séquences à une entreprise, et
l'entreprise les prononce sur un synthétiseur d'ADN.
C'est une machine de la taille d'un photocopieur.
Ils prennent votre courriel et chaque lettre qu'il contient
est remplacée par une grappe de 30 atomes, une grappe pour chaque lettre,
A, T, C, et G de l'ADN. Ils les ordonnent dans le bon ordre,
et vous les renvoient par FedEx.
Vous recevez 250 de ces choses dans de petits tubes dans votre boîtes aux lettres.
Je les mélange, j'ajoute un peu d'eau salée,
et j'ajoute ce long brin dont je vous parlais,
et que j'avais volé à un virus. Ensuite
vous chauffez le tout jusqu'à ébulition; Vous le refroidissez
à température ambiante et, en se faisant,
ces petits brins font la chose suivante :
chacun d'eux se lie au long brin à un endroit,
et ensuite la seconde moitié se lie plus loin
au long brin, et ces deux parties du long brin
se rejoignent, de sorte qu'elles soient collées ensemble.
Donc l'action finale de ces 250 brins est de plier
le long brin dans la forme que l'on recherche;
Cette forme sera approximative. Nous faisons ça dans un tube à essai.
Dans chaque petite goute d'eau vous ajoutez 50 milliards de ces machins.
Vous pouvez utiliser un microscope pour les voir.
Et ce qui est sympathique c'est que si vous changez la séquence
et la formule magique, vous changez la séquence des agrafes.
Vous pouvez créer une molécule qui ressemble à ça, et,
qui aime trainer avec ses potes.
Beaucoup d'entre elles ne sont pas mal du tout.
Si vous changez encore la formule magique, vous changez encore la séquence.
Vous obtenez de charmants triangles de 130 nanomètres. Si vous recommencez,
vous obtenez des motif arbitraires. Sur un rectangle
vous pouvez dessiner les motifs de l'Amérique du Nord et du Sud, ou les lettres "DNA."
Voilà l'origami d'ADN. C'est une façon de faire. Il y a beaucoup de façons
de lancer des sorts moléculaires en utilisant l'ADN.
Ce que nous voulons vraiment faire au final c'est apprendre à programmer
l'auto-assemblage pour pouvoir construire n'importe quoi, voyez-vous ?
Nous voulons être capables de construire des artéfacts technologiques
qui sont peut-être bons pour le monde. Nous voulons apprendre
à construire des artéfacts biologiques, comme les gens, les baleines et les arbres.
Et s'il est possible d'atteindre ce niveau de complexité,
si notre capacité à programmer des molécules atteint ce niveau,
alors ce sera vraiment magique. Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)